maintenant une loi qui permet d'avoir
accès dans certaines circonstances aux
antécédents de violences conjugales d'un
partenaire intime vient tout juste
d'être adopté au Manitoba l'objectif
bien sûr c'est de protéger des victimes
potentielles et le mentoba c'est de la
quatrième province canadienne à se doter
d'une loi semblable après la
Saskatchewan l'Alberta et même
Terre-Neuve labrador on se demande le
Québec pourrait-il emboîter le pas alors
pour en discuter en juin Jean-Claude
Hébert un avocat en droit criminel qu'on
connaît bien bonjour Jean-Claude
bonjour Alors comment ça fonctionne de
qui peut demander quel renseignement sur
qui à qui
ben selon la construction de la loi qui
a sans doute bénéficié comme policier de
l'expérience des autres provinces qui
ont des lois semblables
n'importe qui en principe qui appréhende
ou qui voit un danger de violence
sexuelle ou de violence physique contre
des personnes les enfants les adultes
pourraient donc formuler un signalement
à qui de droit qui doit ici selon la loi
ce sont les services de police qui eux
auront la compétence de faire une
enquête de vérifier le sérieux des
informations et de tirer des conclusions
et faire des recommandations bon alors
justement dans ce fameux texte de loi je
lis que toute personne qui s'inquiète
quand on risque d'un partenaire intime
au risque qu'un partenaire intime
pourrait poser pour sa sécurité donc
c'est un partenaire actuel ou un ancien
partenaires si jamais il y avait des
événements c'est ce que je comprends par
partenaire
ben écoutez si on lit
l'actualité on s'aperçoit que très
souvent dans des drames de féminicides
par exemple
ce sont des personnes qui ont eu un lien
avec la victime donc on veut donner la
chance au service politique de faire une
enquête
générale sur le comportement de
quelqu'un dans le passé soit avec cette
personne là qui fait le signalement ou
peut-être aussi d'autres personnes qui
ont vécu des situations semblables et
qui pourraient disons étoffé davantage
l'enquête parce qu'on veut arriver à une
conclusion qui est percutante est-ce que
cette personne là est un risque réel si
oui je veux dire il faudra passer à une
autre étape
oui mais justement c'est là où ça se
complique un peu je pense parce que on
dit que des renseignements seront
communiqués si la police après avoir
étudié la demande crois ou à des motifs
de croire qu'une personne pourrait en
bénéficier ça c'est très subjectif tout
ça c'est la police qui va sous peser et
estimer si oui ou non à la raison de
craindre
en fait vous avez raison il y a deux
volets de subjectivité ici il y a une
personne qui peut fort bien interpréter
les faits les faits sont les faits mais
peut aussi leur donner un sens peut-être
illimité dans un sens de crainte le
comportement de quelqu'un vous
communiquez ça à la police la police
interprète les faits dans ce sens là ou
différemment et là il y a toujours une
zone grise où les personnes peuvent
erranemment mais de bonne foi se tromper
sur le comportement d'une sieste
personne qui est la personne ciblée par
l'enquête bah oui justement et l'autre
grande inquiétude c'est la protection
des renseignements personnels parce que
la police qui va communiquer ça elle
doit être convaincue que la personne à
qui elle les communique les informations
comprend qu'est-ce que c'est que les
obligations de confidentialité on peut
pas le divulguer à tout va
non et là si on parle du Québec parce
que ça nous intéresse ce genre de loi-là
il faut il faut se rappeler que au
Québec actuellement le législateur est
en train de revoir la loi d'accès à
l'information donc la protection des
renseignements confidentiels au fédérale
on a plusieurs lois qui sont en train de
se mettre à niveau à ce niveau là donc
ça veut dire qu'une loi de type Manitoba
au Québec devrait se retrouver dans un
tourbillon de modification législatives
toujours avec l'idée de protéger autant
que faire ce peu la confidentialité des
renseignements la réfutation des gens
donc j'ai l'impression que le ministère
de justice va jeter un coup d'oeil
intéressant sur cette loi là c'est ce
qui se passe dans un autre province mais
je suis pas convaincu il va se lancer
dans un projet de loi immédiat surtout
qu'avait on expérience du tribunal
spécial ici un projet qui va falloir
avoir des résultats les évaluer et agir
en conséquence mais oui c'était ça ma
dernière question mais vous y répondez à
moitié c'est-à-dire est-ce que
poursuivre ce que les quatre autres
provinces sont faits le Québec va
adopter une loi comme celle-là mais on a
tellement de remue-ménage dans les lois
plus le tribunal
spécial spécialisé en matière
d'agression et de violence sexuelles
mais c'est pas dit je pense que la
sagesse voudrait que le ministre de
justice disent je vais examiner ce qui
se passe ailleurs je vais tenter de
retenir les bons effets et voir si ça
pourrait compléter le projet pilote
qu'on a ici avec notre tribunal spécial
et dans un acte deux ans on verra si
nécessaire d'aller dans la même
direction et bien on aura assurément
l'occasion d'en reparler merci beaucoup
Jean-Claude Hébert
merci au revoir pour voir nos émissions
en entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici
RDI